if flibberty reans are bold impulsive
quick-witted adventurous analytical and
willing to ignore social norms is that
because we have especially active
dopamine and testosterone systems in our
brains that's the hypothesis of the
biological anthropologist Helen Fisher
who has developed a pioneering framework
for classifying human temperament she
categorizes her subjects by having them
take a personality test that's used by
dating sites match.com and chemistry
comm to better link potential mates the
date her questionnaire has been taken by
more than 14 million people in 30
countries Barack Obama for example is
high in dopamine accounting for his
optimism an estrogen which explains the
oval office rug covered in inspirational
quotes Mitt Romney is in some ways the
opposite of a libertarian high on the
serotonin scale which accounts for his
respect for authority rigidity and
loyalty Fischer is a senior fellow at
the Kinsey Institute and she's the
author of six books most recently
anatomy of love a natural history of
mating marriage and why we stray she
spoke at the reason Foundation's annual
donor weekend in West Palm Beach Florida
so anyway I study the brain I and my
colleagues have put over a hundred
people into a brain scanner and studied
the brain circuitry of romantic love
people have just fallen happily in love
people have been rejected in love and
people who are in love long term it's
possible to be in love not just loving
but in love long term but I got to pick
the right person and in 2005 a couple
days before Christmas my phone rang in
New York and it was match.com and they
called me and they said they wanted to
meet with me two days after Christmas to
talk nothing happens in New York City at
Christmastime so I was astonished and I
walked into the room with them and 11
people piled into the room and I had no
idea who they were I thought maybe this
was a think tank and they were other
academics I didn't know anyway in the
middle of the morning somebody it ended
up being the CEO turned to me and he
said why do you fall in love with one
person rather than another and I said I
don't know with all kinds of cultural
reasons that you do but I began to think
people will say we have chemistry or we
don't have chemistry could it be that
nature has
some natural personality styles that are
drawn to one another so I began to think
to myself that I would look into the
biology of personality and see if I
could understand the human mind there's
two parts of personality there's your
culture everything you grew up to do
believe and say and think and there's
your temperament your biology your
predispositions I study your temperament
your nature epigenetics is the newest
thing that's ever happened the most
important thing actually that's ever
happened in my life is the combination
of how these temperament and culture
interact with one another but basically
and I'm going to talk today about your
temperament particularly the temperament
of the libertarian mind there's all
kinds of things that that evolved we now
know that a good 40 to 60 percent of who
you are comes out of your biology and
one of them is how you feel intimacy
women tend to feel intimacy from
face-to-face talking we swivel till
we're face-to-face we do what's called
the anchoring gaze and we talk that's
intimacy to women it probably comes from
millions of years of holding your baby
in front of your face controlling it
representing it educating it with words
men tend to get in received from side by
side doing when he looks up he'll look
away they can see they can watch a
football game all Sunday afternoon and
say almost nothing to each other and get
a great deal of intimacy out of it it
probably comes from millions of years
I'm sitting behind a rock on the
grasslands of ancient Africa trying to
hit that Buffalo in the head with a rock
you can't be talking to your neighbor
when you're doing that kind of job the
problem of course is this remote our
differences so I'm in the business of
trying to find those differences I've
never met two people who were alike I'm
an identical twin even she and I are not
alike entirely alike she's actually a
hot air balloon pilot I'm an
anthropologist she takes people up in a
a little basket I walk on major podiums
and talk about the evolution of adultery
they're very different things but they
both require a certain personality style
so anyway people are different and in
fact there's a lot of new data that a
political scientists now think that
politics is at least 40 to 50% comes out
of your DNA and they've actually coined
a new term called
Geno politics so that's my hypothesis
began with this morning at the mass comm
and I decided I wanted to find out if
we're naturally drawn to one person
rather than another so I decided what I
would do is go through all of the
academic literature looking for any
trade at all linked with any biological
system so for example snips single
nucleotide polymorphisms there's a lot
of genetic differences and I would
collect data on that disease Medicaid
l-dopa if you give l-dopa to a
Parkinson's patient you're driving up
the dopamine system in the brain and
with that it's actually linked with
creativity and I wish I had it I've
never been able to find it since but I
was once talking with the woman who
studied this and she was studying a
woman who had Parkinson's and that woman
was drawing stick figures augs
and then after giving her this woman
l-dopa she was literally drawing dogs
that looked like Rembrandt dogs it was
quite remarkable antidepressants
particularly the serotonin boosters
Prozac Paxil lexapro all of them they
actually reduce curiosity and
exploratory behavior LSD drives up the
serotonin system in the brain the
serotonin system is linked with
religiosity this is one a reason that
people will get a religious high I'm
told
when they take that drug estrogen
replacement really helps with the memory
there's a lot of estrogen receptors in
the hippocampus linked with memory and
if you take ER T estrogen replacement
you're likely to actually to boost
memory and get greater linguistic skills
so by looking at all of these things I
began to find that there were four basic
brain systems that was each one of them
linked with a constellation of
personality traits now there's all kinds
of systems in the brain
most of them keep the heart beating or
the eyes blinking they're not linked
with personality traits these four are
all linked with each one of them a
constellation of personality traits so
what I decide I would do is make a
questionnaire to see to what degree you
express the traits in each one of these
four basic systems now for example I
know that people are very expressive of
the dopamine system tend to be
unpredictable so I created a
questionnaire I find unpredictable
situations exhilarating and I figured
the high dopamine type would say yes I
do I like them should behave according
established standards proper conduct
people who are very expressive the
serotonin system I figured would be
particularly gravitate to that and say
they strongly agreed and on and on
competitive conversations is linked with
the testosterone system and I knew from
other academics that people who they
carry their emotional feelings with them
for hours days weeks or even months or
years linked with the estrogen system so
by constantly putting questions in
taking the ones out that don't work I
established a questionnaire that has now
been taken by 14 million people in 40
countries and about 30,000 people take
it every two or three weeks and so I
keep on perfecting it and at the end of
this I want to give you the most recent
and actually better version of this
questionnaire because my hypothesis is
that you are all going to be quite
expressive
the traits in the dopamine system and in
the testosterone system you're not gonna
have any serotonin in you at all that's
my guess
and some of you are gonna have some
estrogen we'll see about that
but anyway it's a nice scientific
experiment for me and a hypothesis this
is only one person when you take my
questionnaire as Kathryn said we're not
only just one thing this is one of the
problems with all of these personality
questionnaires there in that but the
brain is not buckets
the brain is systems they're constantly
interacting in all kinds of ratios this
particular individual is very expressive
of the traits in the dopamine system and
in the estrogen system so as I say I've
got 14 million of these things and I'm
studying people because I was working
with a a dating service I had to name
them
and so I named people who are very
expressive for the dopamine system
explorers academic term is curious
energetic those people very expressive
with the serotonin system I called
builders not a great term but I'm stuck
with it now cautious social norm
compliant that's not you know is there
very night of the testosterone system
tending I call him the director
analytical and tough-minded and those
expressive particularly expressive of
the estrogen system I call the
negotiator or pro-social and empathetic
so this next slide I is only for me it's
most important one of the most important
things in my life and it is because what
I did is after I made this questionnaire
from looking at the brain literature
I made the questionnaire and then I went
on to do two brain scanning studies to
prove that the questionnaire actually
measures what I say it measures there's
no other questionnaire in the world that
has been able to do that because the
myers-briggs and all the rest of them
they started from linguistic studies and
you can't go from linguistic studies to
make a questionnaire and then go back to
linguistic studies to prove it I've been
able to prove that you are very
expressive of the dopamine system on my
questionnaire you're gonna show more
activity in the dopamine system in the
brain
etc etc so I finally having looked at
this and this is only the second time
I've ever shown this slide only
very recently is what I've really
stumbled on is two basic aspects of all
living mammalian avian reptilian
creatures the degree to which an animal
expresses the trace in the estrogen
versus the testosterone system and the
degree to which they express the traits
in the dopamine versus the serotonin
system what I call the stay and go you
can see a fish you know the fish a
bigger fish comes by and the fish will
step back into its hole because it's
gonna stay on another fish is gonna come
out and take a look at the other fish
and he's gonna go so it's this push-pull
of two basic biological systems of stain
of protection of tradition of
conservative as opposed to curiosity
creativity and exploration so I'm going
to maintain that you are going to
express a great deal of activity in the
go system the plasticity system and a
great deal of expression in the mail
system like the test time there's a lot
of women who have high testosterone and
I say that I'm going to show you why
because I think that these people are
illogical and the one thing I do think
find about libertarians is that your
logical and I would imagine there's
gonna be some libertarians who who fall
within here and I'll be surprised if
there's anybody in the room who is high
on the state system the serotonin system
but we'll see
so anyway I'm gonna go through these
four broad styles of thinking and
behaving linked with the dopamine system
the academic term is their sensations
thinking seeking novelty seeking
risk-taking they're willing to take the
risk they're curious as I say I've got
14 million of these things they're the
most curious they have the most
interests but they're the most likely to
make it through school through college
and graduate school they make the most
money but they also lose the most money
because they're so impetuous
ooh energetic Restless exploration and
it's not just jumping off mountains
if mental exploration also reading the
Opera the theater movies conferences etc
that are they happen to be enthusiastic
and optimistic actually I think that
Obama has quite a few of these traits
also after he first won the first
election the onion the humor magazine
the the lead line was black man given
worst job in the world
and indeed I think it was optimistic
about it I don't know if he's optimistic
today but I would imagine that he's more
optimistic than he should be so
independent that's you as your middle
name is independent self-reliant impulse
spontaneously generous these people will
walk into a bar and buy everybody a
drink spontaneously generous mentally
flexible and open-minded I'm thinking
that that is you but the biggest part of
it is idea generation the dopamine
system is linked with idea generation
verbal and numeric creativity they're
also tactically intelligent the fast
most of the people on TV are going to be
high in the dopamine scale you got to be
quick in the media and I think the last
the vast majority of them are going to
be high dopamine
they can also be susceptible to boredom
that's me
I don't get out of an airplane without
at least I was thinking of him when I
brought down here I brought three books
in case I'm on that tarmac for one month
I got something to do reckless they can
be reckless unreflective they look out
not in I give a lot of speeches to the
therapy community couples therapist
particularly and I I once I said to
myself I mean there was about 600 people
in the room and I said I said well you
know I'm not you know I'm not I'm not
interested in Who I am and some drivers
the back of the room scream you want to
talk about it I said
I didn't they can be manic insincere
opportunistic and unpredictable I did a
study of a hundred and seventy-eight
thousand people
I want that comes out of the 1930s it's
called the lexical hypothesis and the
hypothesis is that you say words that
reflect who you really are
and I wanted to know whether you use
words that reflect who you are
biologically so I collected 178,000 of
these profiles from match.com and
another site chemistry calm and I wanted
to see people who are very expressive of
the traits in the dopamine system the
top ten words they use in describing
themselves and what they're looking for
adventure venture spontaneous energy new
fun travelling outgoing passion and
active and one of the things that I say
when I talk to a business group is
listen not only to the content of a
person's conversation but the words they
use as they are expressing that
conversation it can say a great deal
about the the basic wiring of your brain
so Richard Branson is a good example
I've always thought rules were made to
be broken and that's a how libertarians
feel about that but he's a I've always
had the urge to live life to its full he
went across the Atlantic in a hot-air
balloon without knowing how to uh to
sell it they I want to jump out over a
room Ireland and the other guy jumped
out first and he's floating around in
the sky without in a small basket for
God's sakes ylang-ylang the concert
pianist Flair dazzling charisma bravado
daredevil extremes a very different man
very different part of the world he grew
up in a very different occupation but
the same basic brain temperament and
certainly Peter Thiel a real
entrepreneur one is the first outsider
to invest in Facebook bitcoins now
that's out of the established coinage
system funds all kinds of
new ideas really supports any kind of
individualism that's all
the kind of thing that you would see in
a high dopamine temperament uh he was
also a math whiz and a chess prodigy
and that's testosterone so if I don't
know the man at all and also he's got a
face that shows quite a bit of the
testosterone the very square jaw the
high forehead the heavy brow ridges are
all built by testosterone so if I had to
guess
educated guess I think this would he
would be very high on my scale of the
dopamine and testosterone scale and
certainly a libertarian in love these
people go for people like themselves
they want somebody who's gonna leap off
the couch and go over to the Met at 7:30
in and try and get into the Opera that
night they they get bored easily and
they want a partner who will play ball
with them the people are very expressive
of the serotonin system this I think is
your opposite
it's my hypothesis anyway we'll find out
when you take my questionnaire they this
is straight out of the brain I know even
we know the genetics of observing social
norms they follow the rules they like
the familiar they go to the same place
every summer for summer vacation they go
to the same restaurants in the evening
they hang around with the same groups of
friends they're cautious they're not
scared the academic term is harm
avoidant they're not scared I've got a
friend in New York who's very high in
the serotonin system and when we walk
towards a corner of the street he steps
back I'm likely to run across the street
and he steps back self-controlled is why
you take Prozac or paxil or lexapro or
one of them you're driving up the
serotonin system and creating the calm
the self-control they were all so modest
people and in fact when I work with
match.com and I work with some of these
people one of the things you got to do
in love is not be too modest
you know courtship is not about honesty
even it's about winning and
and and they can be too modest they like
plans rules schedules they follow the
rules
they're orderly they're persistent they
can do something they're very good at
they're very good managers by the way
concrete thinking and I learned my
lesson with this one I had written a
book on this for love and it's called
why him why her and I happen to be in
Seattle and I was a woman interviewing
me for the Seattle Times or The
Washington whatever it is called and I
was telling her about my hypotheses and
these personality styles and love and
everything and the more I spoke to her
the more I realized that she couldn't
stand beige it really didn't good
standing and so I could became more
flamboyant just that's what I generally
am and it didn't work at all and
following morning I read the newspaper
and I was right she couldn't stand me
and I went to the airport and on my way
to the airport and this taxi camera said
Helen get with the program you know you
know what I should have done with this
woman is poor details honor the
cronbach's alpha uh the eigen analysis
my in all the math of every I should
have poured the details on her and she
would have liked me and was at that
moment that I began to realize something
that I've long held which is I don't
believe in the Golden Rule do unto
others as you would have done unto
yourself I believe in the Platinum rule
do unto others as they would have done
unto themselves and you will win so
they're literal detail-oriented we like
I like details but they gotta add up to
something and they're like details just
for details very good with numbers I've
got a belong you take Prozac up X are
you into having more close friends
respect authority follow the most legit
e is in the serotonin sip and loyal
every time I do the math these people
have got to have loyalty I don't
remember the question on the
questionnaire at the moment but you'll
see it soon enough but it's something
like
would you rather have interesting
friends or loyal friends now we all want
interesting friends and we all want
loyal friends but this type cannot
tolerate unloyal friends and the other
three types including me cannot tolerate
uninteresting friends it's a real math
difference in hundreds of thousands of
people
conscientious dependable on the downside
they can be close-minded controlling
that's a big one
controlling rigid stubborn and
moralistic top where'd they use his
family
honesty carrying morals respect loyal
trust trust where they did that one
twice and values really big are the word
values MIT Romney I think is the perfect
example for Newsweek before the when he
was running against Obama I certainly
read his book I don't know if you did
but anyway he's an orderly GAC and I
read an awful lot about him loves daily
schedules loves them respects you can't
be a Mormon without respecting Authority
it's a very hierarchical religion
following a religious guy etc you can
also see the testosterone in him the
heavy brow Ridge is a high cheekbones
the very square jaw and the high
forehead so once again but very high I
think on the serotonin scale which endow
former a president of China the current
one I think is very high testosterone
this guy I think is very high serotonin
by the way there's a gene in the
serotonin system linked with social norm
conformity where in the world do you
think that that gene is most prevalent
Scott shoutout
China China and Japan they don't it I've
been in mantra you have to I've been in
the you know the subway system or the
train station in in in China and you can
see forty little boys lined up waiting
for the train you can't get forty little
boys in New York City to line up for a
train
it's a high serotonin style and I think
Mike Pence is very high on the serotonin
scale this these are the words he chose
that he's a principled conservative and
a common-sense concern I don't think mr.
Trump is going to say he's a
common-sense conservative controlling
guy wants to restrict a lot of things
Evangel evangelical Christian etc and
real nationalism very high I think on
the serotonin scale high serotonin
people are also drawn to people like
themselves
I think Mitt Romney and Anne are a
really a perfect example of serotonin
meets serotonin the third of the broad
styles of thinking and behaving don't
forget we're all a combination of all of
them high testosterone these people
shoot for the stars analytical logical
good at space was good at math
engineering computers or music music I
think Beethoven was high on the
testosterone scale music is very
structural I'm told I'm high domine I
don't hear any structure at all I'm just
swinging to the beat but the bottom line
is these people see the structure of
music experimental very definitely an
inventive rank oriented you inject
testosterone into a dove or a lizard
never in the fight I'm going to fight
for rank high testosterone people indeed
are a very rank oriented and in fact
it's called dominance matching and it's
an academic term I learned my lesson one
night I was a club in New York City it
was a black-tie event and I was standing
there with four men one of them was a
guy from the Wall Street Journal and he
was taking me to the cleaners he was
dining out on how on Fisher just dining
out and the other three were watching
and I got smaller and smaller and
smaller there's two basic animal
postural gestures throughout the animal
kingdom looking little and looking big
it's called crouched and low lobster
we'll do it they'll walk hi and they're
walking leg
guppies will put their fins out and arch
their backs to look big or they'll look
little so I was getting smaller and
smaller this man was going attacking me
and all of a sudden I turn around to him
and I said something vicious I don't
remember what it was but it was also
funny and it all of us were like that
it's called the barred tooth display
chimpanzees do it too you do it when
you're just terrified and we all stood
there like them and I thought to myself
oh if he thinks like a woman he's never
gonna forgive me if he thinks like a man
I will have matched him in dominance and
he will like me this long pause and they
need trendy throws of his age I said oh
when he starts to laugh every death love
all the rest of them laugh and that man
has respected me from that day to this
and so one of the things that I say to
people is with this kind of a person
attacked back and it's a little hard to
do it the second-in-command at match
mesh calm she's the only person that did
take my advice she she's the only one
that attacked the the CEO this was a guy
who ate rocks for breakfast this guy was
but I and and eventually she was the
only person that made friends with him
actually she finally got his job so and
I did it emotionally contained I have a
girlfriend who said to me some time ago
she told me the story about her husband
she said to her husband she said
sweetheart you haven't told me that you
loved me in a month and he said I said
that last month and nothing's changed
emotionally contain decisive old
tough-minded
and direct is that these ones get to the
point on the downside they can be
uncompromising impatient demanding mind
blindness it's an academic term for the
inability to read other people read
posture gesture tone of voice and in
fact I think that maybe the evolution of
why women cry more than men do and we
both both cry but women cry more more
tears and
maybe just saying hey buddy gotta get
rift here there's something going on
there less sympathetic and in Americans
love empathy but when you really think
about it for millions of years I'm an
anthropologist from millions of years on
the grasslands of Africa men had a job
that did not require empathy they had to
catch that baby gazelle slit its throat
and bring it home for dinner they
couldn't start weeping and let it go or
bring it home as a pet and in fact but
men there's different kinds of altruism
men will rush into a burning building
and save people that they don't know
women won't do that women haven't so
it's not that men aren't empathetic we
got to break down the understanding of
what that word means and under certain
circumstances men are going to be much
more what we would call empathetic or
well maybe it's perhaps it's just heroic
nevertheless they on scales of empathy
the high testosterone as they get older
levels of testosterone actually go down
and men become more and more empathetic
and women become more tough minded after
menopause as estrogen goes down
unmasking levels of testosterone so
these are volatile systems but on
average high testosterone type tend to
be less empathetic and aloof they do not
suffer fools gladly I get bored easily
with it top words they use a lot of
different kinds of intelligence but this
is the sort of knowing a lot about a
subject debate geek nerd ambitious
driven politics challenge and real
they're the least likely to be religious
or even spiritual Steve Jobs is a
perfect example you can really see the
testosterone in that face the high
cheekbones a very square drawer the
heavy priorities in the high forehead
self-discipline brash prickly demanding
brutally honest these are the honest
ones perfectionist exacting demanding
impatient and focus all very high
testosterone Trey
Margaret Thatcher they called her the
Iron Lady for some reason and here we
got the epitome of it I would have to I
couldn't I've never shown that slide
before I don't join discuss psychotic
people but he's a testosterone on on
steroids this guy I can say a lot more
about him but we all could so anyway in
terms of love they go for their opposite
high testosterone people tend to go for
the high estrogen type in business I
would guess that they probably are much
more comfortable with people like
themselves highest urge in the last of
the four broad styles of thinking and
behaving Plato called them philosopher
Kings I coined that term web thinking in
the womb estrogen and testosterone watch
over and build the brain and what
estrogen does if you've got the genetics
for it it builds more pathways between
the two sides of the head and the more
pathways between the front and the back
it's a better connected brain it's not
to say that it's any smarter
it's just able to pull out data almost
simultaneously from different parts of
the system so I call it web thinking it
enables people who are high estrogen to
be a very good at contextual holistic
and long-term thinking they're
imaginative as they can create a whole
pile of different concepts very good at
tolerating ambiguity which I think
libertarians are extremely good I think
this is actually one trait my hypothesis
that libertarians would excel on and
mental flexibility very good at what we
call executive social skills a
linguistic reading posture gesture tone
of voice etc intuitive they can get into
your head we now know the biology of
intuition is not magic what they're
doing is they're pulling data out all at
the same time and so they're leaping
over sort of systematic thinking to come
up with a global concept a Nobel Prize
was won for understanding that
empathetic nurturing trusting
it's a strange one trusting as
apologists have long wondered why could
we have evolved the concept of being
trusting you trust the wrong person in
your scrote and it began the reason I
like that so much is because you can
begin to see that this type of person
who's trusting is also good at reading
posture gesture tone of voice
thinking contextually in a long term
tolerating ambiguity in the system and
getting into people's heads so you can
begin to see how a constellation of
personality traits can evolve together
introspective everything has meaning
just the way he slices that lemon for
the drinks at night means we're not
having sex tonight everything has
meaning and you gotta be aware of that
when you're when you're working with
them and they're seeking they're going
in there see khamenei tend to be
agreeable emotionally expressive
and what I call diplomatic intelligence
on the downside they can be scattered
they don't think they're scattered but
the collected data from here and there
I'm Restless think they're scattered
indecisive as I say have an identical
twin sister I'm very high on this
estrogen scale you know where do you
want to go for dinner well I don't care
we go here we go but where do you want
to go you know we can be really I'm not
in my work but very indecisive otherwise
placating they want to please they want
to level the playing field ruminating
they can think over and over and over
about something you know there's some
sort of business meeting and there's a
fight during the business meeting and
afterwards all the men go out and have a
beer and the women go home and think
about it for three weeks and ruminating
gullable they can be too trusting a
hypersensitive backstabbing not gonna
hit you in the face and a stab in the
back and unforgiving they remember high
estrogen remembers what you didn't do
five Christmases ago they remember I
think it's a bit of a blight for for
both sexes and effusive top words is a
passionate real heart kindness says
reader they're the big readers of the
world learning
random like random I just toss wrong
doesn't mind random as long as they can
put a pad make a pattern out of it I
don't mean can do random but the high
serotonin knees order they need order
Obama I think is very high estrogen what
we in the Oval Office he had a rug with
inspirational quotes on it not my
goodness that's high estrogen he's about
to do a TV program I was reading this on
the plane and on the TV but it's almost
gonna I can't remember I should have
read that this morning something almost
a self-help kind of program that's high
estrogen guy Bill Clinton whole world
knows he can't stop talking he's got
good people skills his books I don't
know his book is something like 963
pages I think it's important to have a
synthesizing mind that's what he said
emotionally expressive he feels
everybody's pain very soft face of high
estrogen we've been wondering for some
time when we are going to have our first
female president I think we've had our
first female president and certainly
Charles Darwin that man put together all
living things and also very high
dopamine guy went around the world for
five years etc very different people
very different backgrounds very
different interests but the same basic
temperament so and the highest urge
intends to go for the high testosterone
kind of person this is a map I've never
shown I mean I've never gotten it
published of of America as I say I got
fourteen million of these things high
serotonin I know that should be read but
it's royal blue because I think that's
the appropriate color all over the South
and Midwest they are all a much more
Republican as I say I've got all that
that data and much more religious hiya
sturgeon is in the northwest and
northeast where most of our universities
are
which is educational and reading
everything is loose rolls into
California that's the high dopamine and
all around Washington is testosterone
where they are trying to run the world
or in Alaska where they're trying to
shoot the animals or Nevada where
they're gambling that's very high
so you can begin to see not only how
America sorts itself biologically but
actually if I were to look at the world
it would sort itself very interested in
migration patterns now whereas people
will go to areas where people think the
way they do and so you're gonna see
pools of genes of certain biological and
temperament styles so I think these
things all evolved together there's a
hunting and gathering group as an
anthropologist we think that about early
hunting and gathering bands were about I
don't know 25 individuals maybe 10 or 12
children and 10 or 12 grown-ups and
they're all going over a hill and they
suddenly see some mushrooms but you
can't have all the high dopamine people
saying let's try the mushrooms you're
gonna have some of the highest Arizona
people say it's not in our tradition to
try these mushrooms they gotta have some
dopamine high testosterone people who
say let's have an experiment let's feed
the mushrooms to the dog see what
happens
we're gonna have some my estrogen people
say let's sit down and pull our data
about these mushrooms and I think that
these four broad styles evolved together
sort of to the push and the pull of
societies around the world and once
again I think what I've stumbled on is
these basic styles of thinking of
behaving as centrist certainly this the
go versus the stay stability plasticity
male-female libertarian I think
authoritarian I'm using Nolan's chart
liberal and conservative and indeed
libertarian are taking from this
estrogen personal freedom and from the
testosterone scale economic freedom and
so this is it so here is the
questionnaire I'm going to give it to
you and you gotta take it on a nap when
you do take it you're gonna get this I'm
breaking these scales down nobody's just
one they're not buckets and I've found
actually a lot of men who are very
empathetic but they're not contemplative
they're not they don't ruminate I found
quite a few women who are very good as
system's thinking that testosterone
particularly women in big business but
they're not tough-minded we are all a
combination as I mentioned I've studied
a hundred thousand people and no two
people took this questionnaire the same
way I've never in my life met two people
who I thought were alike and as I say
I'm an identical twin but there's
patterns to nature there's patterns to
culture and there's patterns to
personality so I'm gonna leave this up
while I tell a story and then go a story
is I was in Japan and close with
match.com and they were starting match
Japan so I was hired to go for an hour
and I mean go for the week and talk to
the press and explain these four
personality styles and then the last day
came and my wonderful little hands I
said to my hand
so what am i doing tonight she's wow
we're gonna have a little party Helen oh
okay she said what we're gonna do and
she we pull up to this place and it
looks like the White House and big
columns and I walk into this room is
huge ballroom twice the size of this
room mannequins with wedding dresses on
him and six foot high flower
arrangements etc and she said well what
we're going to do is we've invited the
first
for people who have taken your
questionnaire on match Japan to come to
this party tonight I said well that's ok
that's great
she said well what you've got to do is
you got to explain the form biological
styles of thinking and behaving and then
we're gonna have a little icebreaker oh
okay that's cool oh she says well what
we're gonna do is everybody's gonna take
your personality questionnaire and
they're gonna wear a rubber band around
their wrist our people were very high on
the dopamine scale are gonna wear a
bright yellow one energy fun you know
exploration people who are very high on
the serotonin scale are gonna wear royal
blue stay people who are very found that
testosterone scale are gonna wear a red
one what I call power tie red and then
Treehugger green for people who are high
on the estrogen scale so they're all in
there they're all mixing they're all
wearing one of these bands and I get up
and I explain it and then what happens
is they begin she said well what we're
gonna do next is we're gonna roll out
the bottom layer of a wedding cake for
wedding cakes just a two foot by two
foot bottom layer of a wedding cake four
of them and the four broad styles of
thinking and behaving are gonna go to
different parts of the room and decorate
the wedding cake and you're gonna
comment on it holy [ __ ] this is the
nadir of my scientific life but anyway I
hope they would do it a little
differently and this is what I saw first
thing I did is I went over to the people
who are doing the estrogen cake that
cake was smiling at me wasn't let's be
friends love they right on this side
it's very emotional charming I don't
think you want it on your wedding cake
but it's emotional
charming less connect empathetic wedding
cake then I go to the high testosterone
cake there's no emotion in that cake not
but they decorated around the cake they
thought outside the box
then I went to the high serotonin cake
it's a formal or drooly wedding cake you
know one Kiwi when cherry and kiwi
cherry cherry organized wedding cake
find a person you want and then I go to
what shall I call it the libertarian
cake the dopamine cake when the first
thing I see the crowd process is five
hundred people in the room and I first
thing I see is three men [ __ ] the cake
and then we look up to me and one guy
was standing he looked at me suck took
one look at me he took some flowers out
of a vase that was not part of the
wedding decorations and plunged it into
the middle of the cake and here we have
the libertarian okay so I will conclude
with this as I said I don't agree with
the Golden Rule treat others as you
would want to be treated I believe in
the Platinum rule understand who they
are talk to them so that they can hear
you and you will win thank you
[Applause]